claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors c'est vrai que cela paraît un peu
étrange 1 que la commission européenne
annonce un accord de libre échange avec
le mexique en pleine pandémie
coronavirus qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui en effet ça peut paraître tout à
fait bizarre que la commission alors que
tout le monde nous parle que de la lutte
contre la pandémie nous annonce hier
soir qu'elle a conclu un accord avec le
mexique
alors qu'elle nous envoie une carte
postale un peu exotique disant
finalement j'ai conclu un accord avec le
mexique
alors je crois qu'il faut quand même se
situer la survie dans son contexte
il s'agit de la modernisation d'un
accord qui existait depuis 1997
donc quelque chose déjà d'assez ses
anciens et qui butait depuis deux ans
sur une demande de l'union européenne
qui je crois est est dans l'intérêt de
la france et des autres états membres de
l'union européenne à savoir l'ouverture
des marchés publics puisque les marchés
publics se conclut avec des appels
d'offres relatifs porte pas qu au
mexique comme dans beaucoup de pays avec
une préférence également nationale dans
l'octroi des marchés et l'union
européenne sur d'ailleurs mandat du
conseil parce que ces négociations ne se
font pas dans l'abstrait
elle se fonde sur un mandat très précis
donné par le conseil c'est à dire par et
amant qui avait demandé à la commission
qu'elle obtient l'ouverture des marchés
publics mexicain aux entreprises
françaises aux entreprises des autres
états membres
et il se trouve que alors heureusement
malencontreusement ça c'est peut-être un
brin problème de timing en effet les
mexicains ont répondu cette semaine
qu'il était d'accord avec la dernière
proposition faite par la partie
européenne et ceux-ci déclenchent en
effet la possibilité
d'avoir un nouvel accord de coopération
lorsqu'on insiste sur l'aspect libre
échange bien sûr il contient des
éléments libre échange mais ce n'est pas
uniquement un accord de libre échange
c'est un accord de coopération entre
l'union européenne et ses états membres
et le mexique
je crois qu'on peut dire que en faisant
cela l'europe et le mexique envoie aussi
un message sur la continuité de leurs
relations par rapport au t1 peu
erratique disons de la politique
américaine vis-à-vis du mexique alors le
commissaire européen qui a fait un
communiqué ce matin
phil hogan et nationalité irlandaise
d'ailleurs a dit tout simplement que
bien sûr la lutte contre la pandémie
mobiliser toutes les énergies au sein de
l'union européenne
mais qu'il fallait évidemment ne pas
négliger le programme en faveur d'un
commerce équitable en faveur de
coopération avec des pays tiers parce
que nous en aurons tout simplement
besoin pour reconstruire notre économie
après la pandémie et il a souligné que
cet accord aiderait l'union européenne
bien sûr le mexique aussi à soutenir nos
économies pour créer de nouveaux emplois
voilà alors maintenant qu'est ce qu'il
va se passer cet accord il va être
d'abord être traduit dans les 24 membres
de l'union européenne à prendre un
certain temps
ensuite il sera soumis au conseil aux
états membres pour approbation
puis au parlement européen pour
ratification donc qui a des objections
elles pourront apparaître à la fois à ce
niveau du conseil et au niveau du
parlement leur pelote blanchemaison il
nous reste à peine une minute
quel intérêt finalement cet accord très
utile pour l'union européenne
et puis pour la france en particulier en
quelques mots en effet si vous voulez
les échanges entre
l'union européenne et mexique mexique
est un pays de 126 millions d'habitants
c'est un marché important sont de
l'ordre de 66 milliards d'euros pour les
biens dont 39 sont exportés par les
européennes dans l'union européenne est
excédentaire en matière d' échanges de
biens et on va dire de service 7 environ
20 milliards d'euros
les échanges ont triplé en depuis 20 ans
et effectivement je pense que c'est au
bénéfice de l'europe alors d'un nouvel
accord il y a également un accord de
protection des investissements ce qui
est nouveau ce qui veut dire les
investissements français au mexique
seront garantis qu'ils ne pourront pas
être nationalisées ou détournés et que
c'est une que c'est très important pour
la france d'obtenir naturellement cela
il ya également une clause de lutte
contre la corruption et contre le
blanchiment des capitaux
alors puisque nous n'avons pas beaucoup
de temps moi je voudrais simplement dire
mais c'est pour ouvrir le débat avec les
précédents intervenants pourquoi pas
après tout évidemment il y aura débat là
dessus mais la question est de savoir en
effet si la reconstruction de l'économie
française après la pandémie l'économie
française et économie européenne après
la pandémie se fera dans une économie
ouverte en faisant bien attention
naturellement à relocaliser des
industries clés sur notre territoire ou
bien si nous voulons nous replier sur le
village gaulois
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales